los seres humanos siempre han observado
que si tenemos un cuerpo en movimiento
digamos pensemos no sé en una en una
cajita que está sobre alguna superficie
en movimiento ok esto eventualmente
llegará a un momento en donde ya no se
mueve verdad entonces está detenido
detenido y esto lo han observado durante
muchísimo tiempo digo es algo muy
cotidiano que vemos todos los días
porque nunca hemos visto realmente algo
que si nosotros lamentamos o algo que
esté en movimiento y shepherd y
permanezca en movimiento por el resto de
los tiempos y parece que que esto
realmente se ha observado desde tiempos
prehistóricos bueno no sabemos si desde
tiempos prehistóricos pero si
definitivamente lo sabemos que esa era
la idea común entre los los antiguos
griegos y todo esto se tenía en mente
hasta por ahí de principios del siglo 17
ok entonces por alrededor de 2000 o más
años algo así como dos mil o más años
más o menos se creía que los objetos
tendían naturalmente vamos a ponerlo así
que los objetos tienden obtienen la
tendencia tienen la tendencia a
detenerse la tendencia a detenerse muy
bien detenerse esa era la idea que
perduró durante 2000 o más años es decir
y por el otro lado si nosotros queremos
que algo se mantenga en movimiento
si quieres digamos
si quieres que se mantenga en movimiento
que se mantenga en movimiento piensa en
los siguientes si quieres que tú un
objeto se mantenga en movimiento por
ejemplo si estamos desplazando nuestro
nuestra cajita anterior pues uno tiene
que seguir aplicando fuerzas para que
esta caja siga moviéndose entonces si
queremos que algo se mantenga en
movimiento hay que aplicar fuerza verdad
tienes que aplicar una fuerza
pero esto a principios de digamos del
siglo 17 es decir en los años 1600
aparecieron estos tres caballeros si tú
te preguntarás oye pero porque hay tres
si en realidad este vídeo es acerca de
la primera ley de newton y en efecto
este señor de aquí es sir isaac newton
ok pero también puse las imágenes de
estos dos señores el de aquí es nuestro
famoso galileo galilei bien y el
personaje que se encuentra aquí es rené
de kart muy bien entonces pusimos a
estos a estos otros dos personajes
porque en realidad ellos fueron los que
propusieron lo que ahora hoy se conoce
como la primera ley de newton y debemos
darles crédito por describir describir
este fenómeno antes que él y por
supuesto a newton lo ponemos aquí porque
newton explicó lo que es lo bueno lo que
galileo llamaría la ley de la inercia lo
puso en un
o de teórico de fuerzas por ejemplo la
gravitación y demás y ahora todo eso es
la base de la mecánica clásica que
perduró hasta alrededor del siglo 20
y lo que estos caballeros dijeron y que
es algo bastante o más bien algo que es
muy poco intuitivo es más o menos por
ahí de los años 1600 algo así es en
realidad qué pasaría si todo fuera al
revés es decir que los objetos tienden o
tienen la tendencia de mantener su
velocidad tienen la tendencia
la tendencia de mantener
mantener su velocidad ok eso querría
decir que si por ejemplo algo está en
reposo entonces se va a quedar en reposo
y si algo tiene un movimiento digamos
constante en línea recta sin acelerar
entonces se va a quedar de esa forma
hasta que algo más lo perturbe es decir
esto pasará a menos a menos que se le
imprima una fuerza externa que se le
impriman
impriman exactamente fuerzas
desbalanceadas y cuando digo fuerzas
desbalanceadas es que al menos digamos
que no se contrarresta en verdad fuerzas
desbalanceadas y esto es porque si yo
aplico una fuerza del lado izquierdo y
aplico otra fuerza del lado derecho en
dirección contraria digamos una sí y
otra así entonces si son del sí son
digamos de la misma magnitud la cajita
lo mejor ya no se va a mover muy bien y
tú te preguntarás bueno pero por qué
estará ocurriendo esto o sea tú me estás
diciendo que todo esto ocurre de forma
natural o es lo que al menos nosotros
vemos cómo es que estos tres señores se
les ocurrió bueno en realidad lo que se
les ocurrió a estos tres caballeros es
que quizás el hecho de que se detengan
es en realidad una interacción con el
medio por ejemplo en nuestra cajita que
se va moviendo en realidad tenemos aquí
que se está moviendo sobre una
superficie y este movimiento sobre la
superficie en realidad está generando
una fuerza de fricción que va en
dirección contraria al movimiento y eso
es lo que lo está deteniendo y uno lo
puede entender muy bien porque si uno
empieza a pulir digamos la superficie
hasta que sea muy suave pues este
movimiento será cada vez
más ligero es decir por ejemplo si fuera
un una superficie de hielo la cajita
resbalaría muy fácilmente y se detendría
después de mucho más tiempo que si esto
fuera de piedra
entonces sí que pasaría de entonces si
yo aplico una fuerza a este objeto
digamos que quiero mover una televisión
que está en mi cuarto
de esta forma entonces estos tres
señores te dirían que si tú mantienes la
velocidad de la televisión constante en
realidad es está pasando eso porque
estás contrarrestando es todas las
fuerzas negativas es decir tú estás
empujando quizás de este lado y lo que
está ocurriendo es que estás
contrarrestando todas las fuerzas que
van en sentido contrario al movimiento
muy bien entonces por ejemplo como la
fuerza de fricción que justamente va en
contra del movimiento así que si tú
quieres acelerar el movimiento de la
televisión que estás empujando
entonces tendrías que aplicar mucha más
fuerza en esa dirección